J'ai perdu la tête après être devenu sourd, mais je suis parti
L'Afghanistan est en déplacement Talib Famil Ma Ra
Hamrah Baradaram Khanum Baradar B Famille Ma
Revenez à Marden
Tahd Sal, Muhajir Shaddam et parfois Muhajir Shaddam Wal
Elle a appelé
Badhaash na boden rose buz bod han murmure tag ma
Basar Rad Mad Khar B Tosha Qora Meh Hammah Z Daden
Après Az ou Bazm, son empressement s'est éloigné de Sarar
Le sang n'a pas été trahi par Erdam Taza, Mardam, Radm Set
Saman madad tanan pa rugueux
Shmd
M R M atteint
[musique]
PS
M Khawastam au Tadjistan Az Tajistan Bashour Qada
Je m'amuse vraiment beaucoup, mais je n'y connais rien
Janvier pareil
Ce n'est pas connu
[musique]
Oublié
je